I'm from Nepal I'm from Iraq I'm coming
from Indian I'm from buyer New Jersey I
have been editing Wikipedia since I was
it's powerful to be able to edit and not
only read Wikipedia because it's the way
of imprinting to it your own voice the
knowledge of where you come from your
culture your history
the p20 program was created with the
intention to give free access to people
coming from the emerging countries we
knew at the time that mobile was the
future and we wanted to be prepared to
welcome new readers and editors in these
geographies needed to address the
barrier of cost that's why we asked the
mobile operators to make Wikipedia three
you